[Applaus]
ja liebe Delegierte
ich merke alles in aufgeregt alle freuen
sich auf die nächsten Wochen nicht
begrüße sie auch im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes recht herzlich zu
unserem 14 Bundesparteitag den ich auch
hier mit eröffne und Stelle als
allererstes die ordnungsgemäße
Einberufung fest
diese wurde vor sechs Wochen am 12 juni
einberufen zu unserem Bundesparteitag
regt sich dagegen Widerstand das kann
ich nicht wahrnehmen damit ist der 14
Bundesparteitag hier im wunderschönen
Magdeburg eröffnet und ich bitte Sie
jetzt wirklich die Gespräche
einzustellen
Platz zu nehmen Sie wissen alle ihr
wisst alle wir haben ein straffes
Programm wir haben zwei vollgepackte
Wochenenden wir wollen Programmarbeit
leisten wir wollen unser Verantwortung
gerecht werden und den Wählern hier auch
zeigen für was wir stehen mit welchen
Kandidaten wir stehen und mit welchen
Kandidaten wir zur europawahlversammlung
antreten wollen also von daher bitte ich
wirklich um Disziplin und das ist auch
der Aufruf des gesamten Bundesvorstandes
an sie an euch dass wir diese zwei
Wochenenden in Disziplin in Einigkeit in
Harmonie so wie wir es das letzte Jahr
bereits Leben auch hier heute und
nächste Woche gestalten wollen liebe
Freunde
ich möchte mich
bevor ich einige inhaltliche Punkte hier
ansprecher zuallererst natürlich bei den
Organisatoren auch noch denjenigen
bedanken von der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
die es möglich gemacht haben diesen
Bundesparteitag so ausgestraffieren und
auch diese Vorbereitung zu treffen was
mittlerweile in den heutigen Zeiten sehr
schwer und schwierig ist was viel Mühe
und Anstrengung bedeutet auch mit vielen
ehrenamtlichen Helfern für die ich mich
hier im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes bedanken möchte ich
möchte mich aber auch gleichwohl
[Applaus]
bei der Polizei bedanken die uns und für
uns die Sicherheit hier gewährleistet
eine demokratische legitimierten Partei
diesen Parteitag hier zu ermöglichen
dass wir diesen hier auch durchführen
können und abhalten können dafür vielen
Dank an die Polizei für die Sicherheiten
auch für die nächsten Tage
und ich habe es eingegangen gesagt wir
sind jetzt zehn Jahre alt hinter mir
stehts diese zehn Jahre heißen natürlich
auch für uns dass wir erwachsen geworden
sind mittlerweile sind wir nicht mit die
junge Partei wir sind eine
gesamtdeutsche eine neue Partei aber
nicht mit die junge Partei aber was
haben die erreicht wir haben keinen
Streit mehr in der Öffentlichkeit keine
entzweihung mehr in Sachfragen
stattdessen Harmonie und Einigkeit und
was wir damit erreichen können was wir
damit erreichen können
sehen wir in aktuellen Umfragen 22
Prozent bei Insa stärkste Partei in
Deutschland wenn man die kleinspartei
CSU abrechnet
[Applaus]
ja sogar in Baden-Württemberg sehen und
stehen wir laut einer swr-umfrage bei 19
Prozent und in den Umfragen
zur Europawahl stehen wir bei über 20
Prozent das zeigt wie der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei auf ganz Deutschland
ausstrahlt und allen Mitgliedern die
natürlich ihren Anteil haben unsere
Mitglieder unserer Partei zugute kommen
und auch für die vielen ehrenamtlichen
die überall für uns parteipolitisch
aktiv sind auf der Straße möchte ich
mich im Namen des gesamten
Bundesvorstands bedanken auch ihr habt
daran den größten Anteil vielen
herzlichen Dank
ich möchte mich aber auch gleich wohl an
den gesamten Bundesvorstand richten und
mich auch im Namen meiner
co-sprecherin Alice Weidel beim gesamten
Bundesvorstand für die letzte für das
letzte Jahr bedanken was mit Harmonie in
unserem Bundesvorstand und der super
Zusammenarbeit die ich so vorher noch
nicht kannte wirklich darstellt und was
auch zum Erfolg dieser Partei
beigetragen hat
auch mit der Zusammenarbeit mit meiner
co-sprecherin als
Fraktionsvorsitzende aber auch als
Bundessprecherin ich muss wirklich sagen
ich hätte nicht gedacht oder ich habe es
natürlich gedacht aber es hat sich
besser dargestellt als es jetzt
mittlerweile ist diese Harmonie werden
wir auch in die nächsten Wahlkämpfe
tragen und lieber alle ist ich danke dir
und ich freue mich auf die weitere
Zusammenarbeit für die anstehenden
Wahlkämpfe wir werden genau damit Erfolg
haben liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
aber Umfragen sind keine Ergebnisse auch
das muss man klar sagen was die Bürger
was die Wähler mittlerweile von uns
erwarten und was sie zu Recht erwarten
dass wir diese Verantwortung natürlich
und dieser Verantwortung auch gerecht
werden das geht hier um Glaubwürdigkeit
und deshalb bitte ich auch alle darum
diese Umfragen auch mit ein Stück weit
Demut zu betrachten mit Demut zu nehmen
wir müssen genauso weitermachen wir
müssen weiterkämpfen der Kurs ist der
richtige das Personal ist das richtige
lasst uns gemeinsam genauso öffentlich
weiter nach vorne treten intern
diskutieren intern streiten das hat uns
stark gemacht und dazu sollten wir auch
weiter beitragen jeder für sich und auch
die nächsten Tage auf unseren Parteitag
[Gelächter]
und deswegen ist es wichtig und dürfen
wir uns auch auf diesen guten Werten
eben nicht ausruhen da wäre ich auch
immer wieder den Finger in die Wunde
legen genau das eben nicht zu tun in
Bayern und Hessen werden im Herbst neue
Landtage gewählt und nächstes Jahr
können wir in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg stärkste Kraft werden können
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen und
die Wende zum Guten bewirken wir sind
bereit für mehr das ist unser sloggen
dieses Partei ist
und wie ist eingangs sagte müssen wir
dabei eine Devise verfolgen genauso
weitermachen weiter so wir dürfen uns
nicht in zweien das könnte auch das
Motto übrigens des 14 Parteitages wie es
hinter mir steht auch sein und soll es
sein dieses weiter so der Weg den wir
seit Riesa gegangen sind ist genau der
richtige Weg wir haben uns nicht beirren
lassen und auch nicht durch unkenberufe
und Umfragen sollten wir uns auch nicht
beirren lassen es hieß wir hätten unsere
Potenziale ausgeschöpft es hieß wir
seien immer nur die dagegenpartei nein
liebe Freunde wir haben mit Strategie
und Programmarbeit haben wir in kurzer
Zeit genau neue Potenziale erschöpft wir
haben gezeigt dass wir die dafür Partei
sind und auf der Seite der Zukunft
stehen die anderen sind von gestern wir
sind von morgen und das erkennen immer
mehr Bürger in diesem Land liebe Freunde
ja und sogar Friedrich Merz will
mittlerweile lieber Parteichef der AFD
sein
er nennt er nennt die CDU eine
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
und kürzlich sagte er noch dazu im
Sommer Interview ich zitiere es gibt
eine Regierung und es gibt zu dieser
Regierung natürlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland ja Herr Merz da haben sie
natürlich vollkommen Recht diese
Alternative die gibt es und ich bin
stolz ihr Bundessprecher zu sein aber
diese Alternative ist einzigartig und
unnahmlich wir sind das Original liebe
Freunde und niemand anderes
und Friedrich Merz hat es richtig
erkannt es war falsch eine Brandmauer zu
unserer Partei zu errichten es war
falsch für Deutschland und vor allen
Dingen auch falsch für die CDU durch die
Brandmauer hat sich März auf Koalitionen
festgelegt die unserem Land Schaden wer
Brandmauern baut lieber Herr Merz bleibt
ein Gefangener grüner Ideologie und das
merken immer mehr Menschen in diesem
Land
und nicht umsonst stemmt sich grünen
Chefin Ricarda lang mit vollen Gewicht
allen Versuchen entgegen die Mauer
umzuwerfen aber die Bürger haben genug
von den Grünen sie haben genug von Krieg
und sanierungszwang von der
Industrialisierung und deshalb rufe ich
allen Patrioten in der CDU zu reist
diese schwarz-grüne Mauer nieder
wir sollten aber nicht den Fehler
begehen uns auf die CDU als einzige
Koalitionsoption festzulegen wir
koalieren mit jedem und das sage ich
ausdrücklich der bereit ist Politik im
Interesse der Bürger zu machen mit
Interesse für diejenigen die es gut mit
Deutschland die ist gut mit unserem Land
meinen und das bedeutet aber auch wir
schließen ganz klar eine Koalition mit
den Grünen aus liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
denn eins ist Fakt und eins ist klar und
auch das sehen immer mehr Bürger in
diesem Land die Grünen sind die
gefährlichste Partei Deutschlands das
zeigen sie in ihrer Regierungsarbeit sie
wollen aus einer Industrienation ein
Trümmerfeld machen sie wollen
einfamilienhaussiedlungen im Bund der
Plattenbauten umbauen sie wollen den
Bürger den Saft abdrehen und die
Identität nehmen die Grünen wollen Krieg
mit Russland und mit China dieses Grün
liebe Freunde ist nicht grasgrün sondern
olivgrün und blau und grün gehen nicht
zusammen das zeigt sich
wir sind Protest und programmpartei
gegen eine falsche Regierungspolitik
gehen wir mit den Bürgern zusammen auf
die Straße und bringen auf dem
Bürgerwillen in die Parlamente das war
immer unsere Aufgabe als Alternative für
Deutschland darauf bin ich stolz und
diese straßenbewegung werden wir auch
weiterhin vollumfänglich unterstützen
weil genau das ist unser wichtigstes Ohr
in die Bürgerschaft in das Volk und
darauf bin ich stolz und das werden wir
auch weiterhin forcieren und vertreten
liebe Freunde
wir haben erfolgreich gegen Impfpflicht
und lockdowns demonstriert mit 100.000
Bürgern haben wir die Impfpflicht
abgewendet während des ukrainekriegs
demonstrieren wir gegen Kriegstreiberei
und Waffenlieferungen und für Frieden
durch Verhandlungen und dabei
präsentieren wir und repräsentieren wir
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung im
Deutschen Bundestag ja wir sind das Volk
liebe Freunde
aber wir tun noch viel mehr wir
formulieren Konzepte für eine bessere
Politik für eine echte Politik Wende als
einzige Partei in Deutschland vertreten
wir eine interessengeleitete Politik das
sind unsere Alleinstellungsmerkmale und
nicht nur die Fehler der anderen
Parteien das merken immer mehr Bürger
dass wir uns um das wehe und Wohl
unserer Bürger kümmern dass wir für
Deutschland kämpfen dass wir die
wirkliche einzige Alternative für
Deutschland sind denn wir sagen Politik
muss die Interessen der Bürger verfolgen
wir müssen uns um gute Beziehungen mit
alle Ländern der Welt kümmern und
bemühen anstatt ihnen westliche Werte
aufzuzwingen wir sagen nein zu
Wirtschaftskrieg und Sanktion und ja zu
freien und friedlichen Handel mit aller
Welt wir fordern das andere Länder
unsere Lebensweise respektieren
umgekehrt lassen wir aber auch andere
Länder so leben wie sie es für richtig
halten und wie Sie es wollen das nenne
ich Respekt und nur darauf lässt sich
eine friedliche Ordnung aufbauen Respekt
und Frieden statt Einmischung und Krieg
und genau diese Werte geleitete Politik
der Grünen ist respektlos und verletzt
die Interessen der Bürger die Grünen
wollen andere Ländern erklären wie sie
zu leben haben bundesaußenministerin
bärburg beweist es ja immer wieder in
ihren außen und Auslandsreisen und sie
wird immer häufiger von Staatschefs oder
von ihren Amtskollegen gar nicht mehr
persönlich empfangen etwa in Brasilien
oder auch in Südafrika offenbar hält sie
das Auswärtige Amt mittlerweile für eine
nicht Regierungsorganisation für
feministische Außenpolitik und genau das
ist falsch
genau das ist falsch ein Außenminister
Deutschlands muss allen Staaten mit
allen Staaten respektvoll umgehen das
erwarten wir von einem deutschen
Außenminister diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik hat Deutschland in den
Ukraine Krieg mit hineingezogen ansteht
neutral zu vermitteln hat die andere
Regierung einseitig Stellung für den
Westen bezogen sie missachtet die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands und tut
so als wäre der Krieg 2022 aus heiterem
Himmel ausgebrochen dabei haben genau
unsere vorgehenden
Kanzler wie zum Beispiel ex-kanzlerin
Angela Merkel und Ex-Präsident Francois
doch zugegeben dass minsker-abkommen
hatte 2015 vor allem einen Zweck Zeit zu
schaffen Zeit zu schaffen um die Ukraine
für den Krieg aufzurüsten jetzt sterben
junge Ukrainer in deutschen Panzern im
Kampf gegen Russland das liebe Freunde
ist eine Tragödie und ich fordere
ich fordere Respekt für die Ukraine
ebenso wie Respekt für Russland tatsache
ist nämlich auch dass wir nicht mehr
günstiges Gas aus Russland importieren
ist eben keine Reaktion auf den Ukraine
kriegt Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck hat den Krieg zum Anlass genommen
um die Importe zu stoppen aber er hat
dieses Ziel bereits 2016 verkündet und
zwar Zitat weil wir ein Energiewende
Land sind und ohne den Krieg hätten die
Bürger aber nicht hingenommen dass wir
die Lebensader unserer Industrie
durchtrennen das wusste er jetzt liegt
nordstream gesprengt von den USA und
Norwegen oder von der Ukraine auf dem
Meeresgrund und wir importieren teures
dreckiges trekkinggas aus Amerika die
Ampelkoalition hat das Verbot von Gas
und Ölheizungen beschlossen und was
macht die EU
die plant den wärmepumpenzwang für alle
Mitgliedstaaten und hier muss ich noch
mal an die doppelzinglichkeit und die
Doppelmoral der CDU anknüpfen Herr Merz
sagt er ist gegen dieses Öl und
heizungsverbot was macht aber seine
Kollegin Ursula von der Leyen in Brüssel
in Sachsen plakatiert die CDU
heizungsverbot stoppen was für eine
Doppelmoral genau die gleichen Politiker
wollen dieses Gesetz sogar noch
verschärft im EU-Parlament durchsetzen
und genau dagegen müssen wir auch auf
europäischer Ebene vorgehen und diese
Doppelmoral benennen
und dann schauen wir uns die Geldflüsse
an schauen wir uns die Profiteure an
dieser ganzen Gesetzgebung es ist zum
Beispiel career global der US-Konzern
der das wärmepumpengeschäft des
deutschen Familienunternehmens Viessmann
gekauft hat in havix
Wirtschaftsministerium läuft genau
dieser grüne Sumpf zusammen eine frühere
Blackrock Mitarbeiterin leitet die
Grundsatz Abteilung Staatssekretäre
kommen aus dem Netzwerk des us-investors
hellhörig deswegen legen wir den Sumpf
trocken wenn es die Medien nicht
schaffen muss ist die Alternative für
Deutschland machen das ist unsere
Aufgabe
und wir sehen es wir sehen es in
Deutschland wir sehen es an unseren
Unternehmen diese grüne Energiewende
macht Energie unerschwinglich und
zerstört unsere Industrie sie macht die
Bürger Arm und führt uns in einseitig
Abhängigkeit vom Westen die Beziehung
auf dem Kontinent Europas sind
mittlerweile unterbrochen im Kontinent
steckt ein Keil die USA haben den Keil
in den Kontinent getrieben und die
polnische Regierung treibt ihn mit einer
aggressiven Politik gegenüber
Deutschland und Russland immer tiefer
hinein und unsere Aufgabe liebe Freunde
besteht darin diesen Teil zu entfernen
wir müssen das Netz an Lebensadern und
Transportwegen in Europa und Asien
erneuern das und nichts anderes sind wir
der Welt schuldig liebe Freunde
[Gelächter]
ja und nach Russland wollen die Grünen
sich nun China vorknöpfen die Pläne für
einen Wirtschaftskrieg mit China liegen
schon längst in den Schubladen der
Grünen Ministerien nicht nur von Gas und
ölausrüstung sondern auch von Rohstoffen
und Hightech unseres wichtigsten
Handelspartners sollen wir uns
abschneiden lassen und warum um den
geostrategischen Zielen der USA voraus
ein zu dienen die Ampel hat nun jetzt
eine china-strategie veröffentlicht
dieses Strategie trägt glücklicherweise
nicht nur die Handschrift der Grünen
aufwendige investitionsprüfungen China
sind nicht vorgesehen und eine
Abkopplung auch nicht gut zu muss man
dazu erstmal sagen diese Fragen
sind auch in Zukunft von strategischer
Bedeutung und oftmals wichtiger als die
Frage welcher Parteienfamilie rechnet
sich ein Politiker zu das sage ich ja
ganz deutlich und deshalb auch im
Europaparlament geht es häufig um
Handelsabkommen um Lieferketten die
wertepolitiker mit
menschenrechtsvorbehalten zerschießen
wollen das ist nicht im Interesse
deutscher Bürger liebe Freunde und
dieses Interesse steht im Zweifel auch
über Fraktionsdisziplin jeder
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen den Osten ist
abzulehnen wir wollen Freien und
friedlichen Handel mit aller Welt liebe
Freunde
auch wenn wir unser 14 Bundesparteitag
im Zeichen der Europa Listenwahl die
morgen ja beginnt steht haben wir heute
eine Vielzahl von wichtigen
Satzungsänderungen auf den Weg zu
bringen wir haben bundesschiedsrichter
und Rechnungsprüfer zu wählen wir sind
in den letzten zwei Jahren zu einer
wichtigen Kraft in Europa geworden wir
haben in Europa wertvolle Zeit verloren
auch das müssen wir selbstkritisch
einräumen wir als Partei um einen kurzen
Ausblick auf das bevorstehende
Wochenende zu geben noch paar
abschließende Worte dazu der Erfolgskurs
der Bundespartei ist in Brüssel eben
noch nicht vollständig angekommen die
Politik der europa-delegation liebt zu
lange der Meuten Ära verhaftet was wir
im Bund und in den Ländern erreicht
haben das müssen wir jetzt nach der
Europawahl 24 auch ins Europäische
Parlament tragen und auch diese Ziele
dort erreichen wir müssen Politik machen
die allein an den Interessen der Bürger
orientiert ist dazu ist eine
generationwechsel
notwendig und die heutige EU ist mit
Frau von der Leyen federführend in einer
desaströsen Migrationspolitik und mit
wirtschaftsfeindlichen
sanktionspolitiken dafür steht diese EU
unter der Präsidentin denn die werden
nämlich genau dort gemacht 11
sanktionspakete gegen Russland wurden
beschlossen sie alle Schaden im Bürgern
in der EU mehr als Russland und das
haben wir von Anfang an kritisiert und
bemängelt und die Schaden vor allem
Deutschland zu allererst und wir sehen
die Zahlen der IWF trocknet
prognostiziert das mittlerweile und sagt
es auch dass die deutsche Wirtschaft
weiter schrumpfen wird die hohen
Energiepreise zerstören Existenzen und
haha Weg spricht allen Ernstes von
German Angst wir Freunde das ist die
verächtigungmachung des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers gegenüber der
deutschen Wirtschaft der Industrie der
kmuos den Frieden fleißigen Handwerkern
letztlich von uns allen und deshalb rufe
ich auch hier heute deutlich alle
Interessenverbände
handwerkerverbände Industrieverbände auf
sich endlich lauthals dagegen zu werden
die Zeit der Kompromisse ist vorbei sie
werden die Kurs sonst nicht ändern
[Gelächter]
denn fest steht auch Sanktionen
schädigen dauerhaft die guten
Beziehungen zwischen Nationalstaaten
machen wir also nicht den Fehler auch
hier Russlands zu früh abzuschreiben in
Südamerika Afrika und Asien entziehen
sie Staaten mittlerweile diesen
Sanktionen sie gründen neue
Organisationen und setzen der unipolaren
Weltordnung eine multipolare entgegen in
dieser Ordnung wird Russland auch in
Zukunft eine wichtige Rolle spielen und
deswegen sage ich auch hier deutlich ja
zur Diplomatie aber auch hier muss man
bei aller berechtigter Kritik am besten
eingestehen das auch Russland bislang
Angebote zu Vermittlungen und
Verhandlungen beispielsweise von China
nicht wahrgenommen hat jedoch ist dieser
gegenseitige Respekt in einer
multipolaren Welt unabdingbar denn
Multipolarität bedeutet nicht mehr eine
einzige Weltmacht beherrscht die Welt
mit ihren Werten sondern mehrere
gleichberechtigte Mächte setzen in ihren
Regionen ihre Vorstellungen von Recht
und Ordnung durch und deshalb früher
oder später wird diese multipolare
Weltordnung auch Europa erreichen und
dann bietet sich die Gelegenheit
gegenseitige Abhängigkeiten abzustreifen
und neue Optionen zu eröffnen wollen wir
dann
wollen wir dann diejenigen sein die
Brücken gesprengt
oder wollen wir diejenigen sein die
Brücken gebaut haben wir wollen als
Alternative für Deutschland Brücken
erhalten Brücken aufbauen das ist unsere
Vision für Europa und dafür kämpfen wir
auch im EU-Parlament
und wir dürfen vor allem die nationale
Frage und die europäische Frage eben
nicht länger getrennt betrachten wenn
wir in Deutschland die Wände zum Guten
bewirken wollen dann müssen wir unsere
Arbeit im Bundestag in den
Landesparlamenten und in den kommunalen
Räten in Brüssel und Straßburg auch dazu
flankieren es wird nämlich keine Wende
in nur einem einzelnen Staat Europas
geben entweder Europa Staaten erlangen
gemeinsam die volle Souveränität zurück
und bestimmen wieder selbst über ihre
Geschicke oder europa bleibt in Gänze
ein Anhängsel des Westens das ist die
bittere Wahrheit liebe Freunde meine
Damen und Herren in der wir uns stellen
müssen Europapolitik ist von enormer
Bedeutung hast du einen Opa dann schicke
Ihnen noch Europa so hieß es mal diese
Devise gilt aber schon lange nicht mehr
in Brüssel laufen wie unter den
Brennglas die weltpolitischen
Entwicklungen zusammen die auch unsere
Politik in Berlin in Dresden in Erfurt
in Mainz in Wiesbaden oder in München
beeinflussen
wollen wir mit unserem erfolgshaus auch
einer Alternative für Europa sein und
werden dann müssen wir in Straßburg und
Brüssel unsere Interessen geleitete
Politik vital und selbstbewusst
vertreten deshalb lasst uns auch die
nächsten zwei Wochenenden kämpfen dafür
für dieses europawahlprogramm für unsere
Kandidaten aber auch auf unserem
Bundesparteitag für Freiheit für
Souveränität für Frieden wir sind bereit
liebe Freunde vielen herzlichen Dank